- I met Joe, my co-founder,
and both of us had this dream
that we were going to do something
that would make an impact
in the world, and we didn't
even know what that meant.
I think a key thing to
learning is having mentors.
And a key thing to having
mentors is being shameless.
Start with the perfect
experience of just one person.
Get that right, and then figure out
how to scale something great.
He said, "Brian, start-ups
die of suicide, not homicide.
"All great companies that had a downfall,
"they died of self-inflicted wounds."
Everything around you is
designed by somebody else,
if it's manmade.
You can redesign the world you live in.
If you know those binders
you put baseball cards in,
kids with baseball, we
put credit cards in those.
We had sleeves of credit cards.
Five star is what people expect
but to build something
people love you almost need
to do something more than they expect.
- He's an American internet entrepreneur.
He's best known as one of
the co-founders of Airbnb.
He was named one of Time's
100 Most Influential People of 2015.
He is Brian Chesky, and here is my take
on his top ten rules for success.
- When I got to RISD Art School,
and everyone was like
creating their own projects.
And I had a teacher who
said, "You're a designer.
"Everything around you is
designed by other designers.
"You can design the world you live in."
I met Joe, my co-founder,
and both of us had this dream
that we were going to do something
that would make an impact on the world,
and we didn't even know what that meant.
I got this job at an industrial
design firm in Los Angeles.
It had health insurance.
My life felt a little
bit like I was in a car,
and the road in front, it's
like, you look out of a car
and the road in front of you
looks exactly like the road behind you.
And you're like, that's your life.
And something about that
really terrified me.
Joe had been calling me up
to try to get me to start a company.
And then one day I go into work,
and I quit my job.
I'm living in a house in Los
Angeles with three friends
and I tell them I'm leaving Los Angeles.
And I pack everything in the
back of an old Honda Civic.
A foam mattress, $1,000
in the bank account,
hardly any savings or any money.
I have to pursue the dreams.
I'd rather fail doing something I love
than always wonder what could have been.
And so that one weekend,
it's October 2007,
I drive to San Francisco,
and that was the beginning of Airbnb.
When I came to the valley,
I did not know much about Silicon Valley.
In fact, somebody told me
there are these people called angels.
I had no idea they meant angel investors.
I think a key thing to
learning is having mentors.
And a key thing to having
mentors is being shameless.
In other words, shameless
people learn really quickly
and are successful.
Most people are just afraid
to ask people for help.
And so we, Joe, Nate and I, were shameless
about asking people for feedback.
Whether it was just our investors
or meeting famous entrepreneurs
like Mark Zuckerberg
or Jeff Bezos, who ended
up becoming an investor,
or Warren Buffet.
You know, you seek out people,
and most people are really nice
and they'll help you if they can.
And Paul Graham said something to me
that I'll never forget, and
he's now written an essay about
he said, "Do things that don't scale."
And it's counter-intuitive.
And what that meant
for us was we were able
to go door to door meeting
every one of our users,
trying to provide an amazing experience
and if we had only relegated
ourselves to a bedroom
or our office, apartment, you know,
because that's the only
thing that seems scalable
we would never have created
an amazing experience.
And often times the best methodology
is to start with the perfect
experience of just one person.
Get that right, and then figure out how
to scale something great.
Instead of scaling something not so great,
and then trying to improve it.
That's really hard to do.
I get to San Francisco, I
had a rent check of $1,150.
And I have $1,000 in the
bank and I can't pay rent
let alone live in San
Francisco, it's very expensive.
And Joe had the same problem.
The first weekend we were there,
This international design conference
is coming to San Francisco
and all the hotels
they're recommending are sold out.
We said well what if we
could just turn our house
into a bed and breakfast
for the design conference.
I mean, people need housing,
we certainly need money.
We didn't have any beds,
I'd just moved up there.
And Joe said, "Don't worry,
I have three air mattresses."
And we called it not the Bed&Breakfast,
but the AirBed&Breakfast.
We built this website
and we ended up having
three people stay with us.
We made enough money to make our rent,
but we also made some deep friends.
And that was the very beginning
of something that we saw.
Many people told me it was
the worst idea they'd ever heard of.
It was months and months
and months of people trying
to talk us out of our idea.
And so we had to continue to think,
like look at the mountain top
and not worry, and not look down.
You know, Paul Graham, I used
to, he was our first investor
and I used to worry about
all these random things
like competitors, like,
you know, kind of cities,
all this stuff.
And he said something
to me I'll never forget.
He said, "Brian, start-ups
die of suicide, not homicide.
"All great companies that had a downfall,
"they died of self-inflicted wounds."
So what are those self-inflicted wounds?
- That's a horrible thing to say!
- I know.
- But anyway.
- But it's really, the key
thing is it's about like,
there's this thing like
you're a small company
and you exist cause no one else,
especially big companies
couldn't do what you could do
as a small nimble company.
You know Pablo Picasso's
saying, "The older you get,
"the stronger the wind gets.
"It's always in your face."
It's like small companies
become big companies
and sometimes they become
really bureaucratic
and the culture gets lost,
people leave the company.
That is something, it's
not unique to Airbnb.
But that's the thing that
we have to worry about
and I'm deeply paranoid about that.
I want to make sure that
we're always a start-up.
Maybe the world's biggest
start-up, but we stay there.
- So you're scared of yourself.
- You have to be afraid
of what you might become
if you're not like, you know,
if you relax, that's for sure.
We believe in an unreasonable vision
of the way the world could look.
And we believe that world can be designed.
I mean, I had a teacher at RISD,
and he told me, "Brian, you're a designer.
"Everything around you is
designed by somebody else
"if it's man-made.
"You can re-design the world you live in."
I think so many of us go through life,
or not people here, but a lot of people
go through life thinking
they're living in someone else's world.
We enter someone else's world
but we leave our world behind.
The world that we've
contributed to in design.
And I think the sense that
anything can be rethought,
anything can be designed.
Anything around you is just,
somebody else did that
with less information than you have today
is an unbelievably empowering idea.
And as I think about running Airbnb
I don't try to presume any
convention of running a company.
Anything can be done a little bit better
if you just imagine like
where you want to get to.
We tried to raise $150,000
and sell 10% of the company.
That would have been an amazing deal.
And we got introduced to
more than a dozen investors.
Most of the investors
that we got introduced to
didn't even return our
phone calls or emails.
A few of them wrote back and
say, "This is not something
"we're interested in."
And the very few that met
us did not give us money.
We're AirBed&Breakfast,
the air beds aren't working
maybe the breakfast will work (laughs).
So we decided, let's sell
collectible breakfast cereal.
Obama O's, the breakfast of change.
And then we we also came up with
a John McCain-themed cereal.
We ended up making 1,000 boxes of cereal.
We sold them for $40 a box,
and we made almost $30,000.
And this is how we funded the company.
Before that, we were funding
the company on credit cards.
I don't know if you know those binders
you put baseball cards
in, kids put baseball,
we put credit cards in those.
We had sleeves of credit cards.
I would go to sleep, and I'd
wake up, kind of like (gasps)
and my heart would be
pounding, and I'd be like,
oh my God, like, how did I get
myself into this situation.
I have no money, like
we launched a year ago,
we still have no customers,
the people don't like the idea,
and what are we going to do, and now what?
I kept saying now what, and like,
when is this going to happen?
And then you get the courage
over the course of the day,
and you find a new plan,
and you get through the day.
And you go to sleep confident.
You're like, you know what?
It's going to be fine.
And tomorrow's a new day.
And you go to sleep.
And you wake up.
And you're (gasps) oh my God!
And your heart starts pounding again.
We had launched three times.
We launched, no one used it.
We launched, we launched again.
And a year later, we
have almost no customers,
tons of credit card debt,
and every investor we knew said no.
Many people have asked me, "Why?"
"Well, why didn't you
lose hope at that point?"
And I guess I just believed in the idea.
And we believed that if
people could experience
what we've experienced, then this would
be an idea that would spread.
They just needed to experience it
and it would just take more time.
One of the most common things people say
when they hear about
the idea of Airbnb now
when they see people all
over the world doing it
is, "Why didn't I think of that?
"It's such a simple idea,
why didn't I think of that?"
You might not have thought of that,
is because when we thought
about that years ago
the most common thing people
said is, "Are you nuts?"
When we design products, we imagine, okay,
this is what customers expect,
They expect to have a
five star experience.
And then we basically ask
the (mumbles) question.
So let's take airport pick-up for example.
What's a five star check-in
experience on Airbnb?
The five star check-in experience
is they give you the address,
you get to the house,
you knock on the door,
and they're there.
And they open the door and
they let you in the house.
And that's five star.
And anything worse than that,
and you start to leave, like,
four stars is you call them,
they're like five minutes away,
you'll probably leave a four star.
And like one star is obviously
like they never showed up.
So the bar's kind of low,
like you knock on the door
and they open the door,
that's a really low bar.
So we ask what's a six star?
Well a six star is they probably
pick you up at the airport.
So you don't knock on their door,
they actually pick you up at the airport.
So what's a seven star review?
You can actually play,
this is kind of fun.
Well a seven star is they don't
pick you up at the airport,
they send a limousine, and
you open the limousine door
and they know that you
like, I dunno, Pringles.
Sorry, that was a weird
example, this is all,
this is like improv so
we're growing with it.
So there's Pringles there, and
there's like coconut water,
and they know you're into surfing,
and there's some surfing magazine
even though you're in San Francisco
you're not going to surf, that's fine.
And so that's a seven star.
So what's an eight star pick-up?
Well an eight star check-in is, you know,
there's a, you get to the airport
and they're like we're coming.
And you're like where are you?
And all of a sudden you
see like a giant elephant.
And that elephant is walking
by the gate, the terminal.
And there's a parade in your honor,
and you get on top of the elephant
and you are paraded away.
(crowd laughs)
And you said, well what's
a nine star check-in?
If that's an eight star check-in
how do we get a nine star?
A nine star check-in is
you get off the plane
and the moment you step off the plane
there are 5,000 screaming
13 year old women and boys.
And their holding signs.
I call it the Beatles check-in.
It's The Beatles in 1964 and
they're coming to America
and they're just cheering
for you, screaming for you
and you basically, they follow you
and they do a press conference
in the front yard of your Airbnb.
(crowd laughs)
And so then what's a ten star check-in?
Well, I can go to 30, but I won't.
Because it'd be a long day.
The ten star is you,
you get to the airport
and there's a little card
and it's got your name on it
and you're like great, there's my ride.
But you realize the person
dressed in the limo suit
is Elon Musk and he
just takes you to space.
(crowd laughs)
And,
so,
I've exaggerated to make a point,
usually we don't go all the way to ten.
The whole point is that like,
if you, if what you need to do
is just find a hundred people to love you
then it's very easy to take for granted
the five star is what people expect.
But to build something
people love you almost need
to do something more than they expect.
And so, like, every
moment is an opportunity
to do something slightly
more than people expect.
And we play this out, you go
to like, all the way to ten.
Okay now we're not going to do all that.
But maybe, suddenly six
stars doesn't seem so bad.
Now we should have a
service, airport pick-up
or something like that.
And so we do this about every
frame of the experience.
And this also can apply to
almost anything, office assign,
or how you hire people.
Like, you know, we storyboard end to end
the interviewing experience.
This August we had on a peak
night one million people,
more than the population of San Francisco,
staying in a home around
the world, in 180 countries.
In one of the stories I heard,
was this host, his name is Sebastian.
And he says to me,
"Brian, there's this word
"you never use in your website."
And I said what's that word?
And he said, "That word is friendship."
He said, "Six months
ago, the London riots,"
this was a couple years ago,
"broke out outside my home.
"And the next day my mom called
me to make sure I was okay."
He said, "Here's the interesting thing.
"Between the time the riots broke out
"and the time my mom called me
"was a 24 hour period of time.
"And in that period of time," he said,
"seven of my previous
Airbnb guests called me.
"Just to make sure I was okay."
I wonder how many of these
people would have called
a hotel, by the way.
But the point is, that
Airbnb is not about spaces.
And it's very easy to come to our website
and see a couple million spaces,
but it's really more about the people.
And our mission is to provide this feeling
not of space, but belonging.
And we belong at home, we
belong at our work sometimes,
but we want you to be
able to belong anywhere
in the world in 34,000 cities.
- Thank you so much for watching,
I made this video because Senay Geletaw,
I really hope I pronounced
that properly, asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments
and I will join in the discussion.
I'd also love to know
which of the top ten rules
resonated the most with you.
Leave it in the comments and
I will join the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.
- Airbnb, we created the company
not because I wanted to be
some successful entrepreneur
and make a bunch of money.
If I was going to do that
I would not have started
air beds for conferences
around the country.
That was not going to be a good idea.
In fact,
I had a mentor,
I told him about the
idea of AirBed&Breakfast,
and he told me, "I hope that's not
"the only idea you're working on."
(laughter)
And my mom, growing up,
all she ever wanted,
because I went to art school.
She said, "Just make sure you get a job
"that has health insurance."
When we created AirBed&Breakfast,
she said, "I guess you never got that job
"with health insurance.
"This is what happens, you start having
"to let strangers into your homes."
But one of the things
we did a few years ago
is we had to ask ourselves
what business are we in?
Are we in the business of homes?
Are we in the business of space?
We made a decision a couple years ago,
and we said, "We're not in the business
"of homes or space, we're
in the business of trips."
That's what we're in the business of.
You travel to have a
trip, not to have a space.
And so a space is a part of it,
but we're in the business of trips.
And we created this thing
that we call Snow White.
It was basically, we storyboarded out
what the perfect trip would look like,
and we said, "We're
only present right now,
"in a few of these frames.
"We want to get to a
place where we're present
"throughout the entire journey."
And so obviously like dining in homes
is one experiment that we're doing,
you know, we have tours,
that's another experiment.
But there's a lot of different things.
We haven't officially unveiled anything.
We want to make sure
when we launch something
it's truly amazing.
We may very well be the
first website on the internet
where you could actually
book with somebody else
and pay them directly.
In other words, there was
eBay, and eBay used PayPal.
But you didn't feel--
- Before PayPal there was checks.
- There was, yeah, yeah, checks, exactly.
And we had, there wasn't
a lot of legacy there,
you know, because we looked
at, there was eBay and Etsy.
And they were both before
us, and Etsy used PayPal,
and both of them you would
book and it would send you
on a PayPal gateway, and we wanted
to feel like booking a hotel.
You never leave Airbnb, we would hold,
collect, remit the money, and so,
whereas they were paying direct.
And they would take a cut,
and there was two different payments.
So we, and that was kind of a crazy idea,
it almost scared us.
It seemed insane that like,
you would actually be
able to pay somebody else
and be able to book something with them
and you'd get a reputation system.
And we decided let's just do it.
And at the time we're like,
this is a little too crazy,
it's a little too scary,
I don't know if we're allowed to do this,
I'm not sure if it will work.
We decided to do it anyway.
And so then in the summer of 2008
We ended up basically designing
the final version of the product.
So we design this product
where you could book someone's
home anywhere in the world.
We had a rule.
Three clicks to book it button,
because there was so many clicks
and so many different ways to get a home
that it was just too hard.
And I remember hearing the story
of when Steve Jobs developed the iPod.
No matter where he was in his iPod,
he wanted to make sure
he was always three clicks from a song.
And we said, "We should
always be three clicks
"from being able to have a paid booking."
And so we created this,
basically, a home page
with a search bar, listings, the home,
and that's exactly the
product as you see it today
with reviews, payment
system, and customer service.
And we basically end up landing on that.